data science for biologists is an online
pilot program that will be run by sister
Nevada the University in Kolkata the
program is going to be dedicated to bind
firm ethics and will talk about the
application of data science in biology
biotechnology and healthcare the program
is a result of a collaboration between
sustainability University Kolkata and
Pine biotech the first pilot course will
run for three months
this will include 13 workshops that will
be followed by a team project out of the
13 workshops ten workshops will be
completely online and three workshops
will take place in a new campus in new
town the three workshops can be attended
online as well from any part of the
country the program will run by
experience by informaticians who have
experience in both academia and industry
dr. Pradeep Chakraborty holds a PhD in
by informatics and after Mohit Mazumdar
holds a PhD in computational biology and
machine learning together they would be
working with faculty and students in
sustainability' University helping
understand various types of
bioinformatics applications including
processing of next-generation sequencing
data applications of various analysis
tools including machine learning tools
and interpretation this program will be
followed by a project where each faculty
member and a group of students will be
able to prepare and submit a poster or
finished analysis of a project that they
have selected
we will start off with a workshop at the
sinew on 20th of august where the
program will be introduced by the
respected PC the Ole Miss logic program
includes various tools and resources
that are provided in the scope of this
pilot that includes online courses
projects and datasets that are already
uploaded on our dban 4 platform we will
also talk about expectations and
schedule of the training program
including important deadlines we will
talk about big data environment X the
topic that we will cover includes
knowledge driven versus data driven
discovery examples and various
applications in biotechnology
agriculture research cancer biology
immunology and various interests
industries like defense and healthcare
in the next call we will dive into the
interesting aspects of genomics we will
talk about the emergence of high
throughput experiments in life sciences
how the central dogma of molecular
biology that DNA code transcription of
the genes and translation into protein
can be measured in a qualitative and
quantitative way we will talk about next
generation sequencing how we can use
this technology to detect DNA variants
and measure RNA expression then we will
transition into transcriptomics a
section dedicated to gene and isoform
expression in the context in this
section we will talk about the role of
pre-processing various mapping
techniques and quality quantification of
genes and isoforms in a sample in the
next call we will then talk about the
analysis of variance how we can use
filtering noise reduction and
normalization techniques to explore
large multi-dimensional datasets more
accurately and summarized what we have
found using analysis of variance how can
we look at outliers various techniques
so that we can detect groups and trends
in the data
this was followed by an on-site workshop
at a Sanu on 10th of September 2019
where we will discuss the role of both
Gino makes em transcriptomics in modern
biology then we'll talk a bit more about
metagenomics the microbiome is a hot
topic and we will discuss about the
reason and the significance of
metagenomics including how next
generation sequencing of 16s
hypervariable region help us understand
the composition of the microbe then the
tech tsunami of the bacteria found in
that those specific samples we will also
talk about significance of gut
microbiota for human health in
metagenomics pan we will discuss the
various research areas and topics in
metagenomics how to practically build a
metagenomics pipeline and various
methods that are used for interception
interpretation visualization and
analysis of result in the introduction
to machine learning section we will talk
about various supervised and
unsupervised machine learning methods we
will talk about regression factors and
features and we will also talk about
various challenges associated with
different types of methods in machine
learning water we will learn about
decision trees discriminant analysis and
support vector machines we will use
feature selection and then we will talk
about how do we expand the number of
features that we want to include in our
analysis we will talk about
dimensionality reduction and various
data visualization techniques finally we
will come to a stage where we can
transition from theoretical learning and
hands-on from a described data set to a
new data set or an independent project
here we will talk about identification
of correct data set for a bioinformatics
project this will help us plan a team
project as we embark the analysis joint
significant time will be allocated for
team projects and throughout we will
meet and discuss the selection and
preparation of various project
components on the neck tail that is on
25th of October we will have a workshop
which will have Q&A session with
students and faculty and then transition
to post a preparation guideline the
topic that we are going to cover in this
workshop is multi-omics data analysis in
cancer research
the hands-on sessions will be conducted
online and offline and will be led by
dr. Pratt in Chakrabarty and dr. Moore
with Mazumdar throughout the program
each student will have access to our
online learning platform that contains
courses project examples and also helps
monitor progression so that each person
can look at their progress by looking at
the various courses that they have
completed and the points they have
accumulated in the process of doing
various tasks associated with these
courses even now the topics we have
covered might sound technical and
complicated but you don't need to be
worried because we have a fully
interactive online platform that anyone
even with the most basic computer skills
can use that means that complex
bioinformatics methods running
computationally intensive pipelines and
visualization of results can be done in
a simple point-and-click interface for
those that have followed the program and
have completed the necessary material a
certificate of participation will be
offered once finish the program we are
also planning for a joint conference
with cisterna with the University where
the participants of the data science for
biologists will be given a platform to
present poster and give small scientific
talks we hope that you will join us for
this exciting course in data science for
biologists we are excited to work with
sustainable data University Kolkata to
introduce by informatics to a wide range
of students and faculty and see how
together
we can develop impactful project to help
understand the application of
bioinformatics today in various domains
including healthcare biotechnology
biochemistry and the application in
agriculture neuroscience oncology and
immunology